-It is time to play
"Can You Feel It?"
-♪ Can, can,
can you feel it? ♪
-But I'm gonna need someone,
some help here.
She is a fashion icon
and the co-founder of
Victoria Beckham Beauty,
please welcome Victoria Beckham!
-♪ Can you feel it? ♪
♪ Can you feel it? ♪
[ Applause ]
-Come on, look at that.
That's all the love for
Victoria Beckham. Come on.
Are you...?
-Oh, my gosh.
-No, no, no, Victoria.
Alright, alright.
Have a seat.
Now here's how this
is gonna work.
We're gonna have a number of
mystery objects
brought out in front of us,
and our job is to guess
what each one is.
The catch is that we have to
figure it out by touch alone.
-[ Gasps ] I am more nervous
than singing in front of
90,000 people
at Wembley Stadium right now.
I am so nervous.
-Me too, by the way.
I do not love this bit,
but I love you
and now we're gonna do this.
Now, Victoria, since I'm
the host, I'll go first.
[ Imitating Victoria ]
Are you sure?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, let's get
our first object.
I will have --
[ Clears throat ] --
30 seconds to identify
what this is.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Cheering ]
-[ Laughing ]
Audience, you're not
helping at all.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
Okay.
♪♪
-I already have a weird
smell already!
There's a weird smell to it.
Ahh! Ahh...
[ Laughing ]
I'm freaking out, I swear.
I don't like this bit.
-It's really gross.
It's really gross.
[ Audience groans ]
-Stop, stop, stop.
You're not helping at all.
-Oh, my God.
-Ooh.
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
-I have no clue!
What this is!
♪♪
Do I have to pick it up?
What am I doing?
-Audience: [ Scattered ] Yes!
[ Chanting ] Pick it up!
Pick it up!
Pick it up! Pick it up!
[ Chanting continues ]
♪♪
-Oatmeal?
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-What was it?
-It's a pumpkin.
-Oh, it's a pumpkin.
You guys are the worst!
[ Applause ]
That's nothing! A pumpkin?
Also, Tariq,
I'm mad at you, too,
'cause I looked at you
and you were freaking out, too.
Ahh. Alright.
-Your dance moves, by the way.
Your dance moves
when you get nervous
and you do that funny,
little thing.
It's fantastic.
-That? Alright.
-I love it.
-I like that.
Victoria, you're up,
and you're our guest,
so we'll probably
go easy on you.
It'll be fine.
Don't worry about it.
-Can you help me out, please?
I didn't realize
how nervous I was.
[ Audience groans ]
That's not helpful!
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
-Let me see. Let me look at it.
I swear,
I'll be honest with you.
[ Laughing ]
-I'm really...
-Oh, my goodness.
♪♪
-Oh, my God. This is horrific.
Help me! Help me!
[ Applause ]
-Oh, my God.
Oh!
[ Applause ]
Oh, my God. I am literally --
-Do you smell something?
Does it smell weird?
-No, but I feel like
it's vibrating.
♪♪
What is it?
It --
♪♪
-You can't do that!
You cannot do that to her.
-It's a weird, vibrating thing.
-She gets mad!
No, you know what it is?
It's the creepy doll
from "Squid Game."
-Oh. Oh!
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-I know, it's...
It's frightening.
Mine was a pumpkin,
and I almost wet myself.
Alright, here we go.
It's my turn agaiiin!
How many rounds of this
is there?
[ Audience groans ]
-It's just so gross.
It's just...
-Ew.
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
-Ahh!
-It's really -- it's gross.
It...
♪♪
[ Cymbal crescendos ]
Stop playing the music!
The sound's driving me insane!
It's getting crazier
the closer I get to touching it!
And I don't like it at all!
I love you, Victoria, but I
can't let you see me like this!
This is awful.
Ahh!
[ Audience groans ]
Ohhh.
-Pick it up!
-[ Chanting ] Squeeze it!
Squeeze it!
-Ahh!
-Squeeze it! Squeeze it!
Squeeze it! Squeeze it!
-Squeeze it!
-Squeeze it?
-Squeeze it.
-I'm not gonna squeeze it.
-Squeeze it!
Squeeze it.
-No, I'm not squeezing it!
I'm not.
I'm done. I'm done.
I'm not squeezing it. Ever!
In my life.
[ Laughter ]
I'll take the loss on this.
What was I holding
and squeezing?
-A hairy egg.
-Ew!
[ Applause ]
-Come on, disgusting!
Eggs? Hairy eggs?
I knew it was something
that smelled.
Alright, Victoria,
here comes yours.
This is gonna be great.
We might end on this.
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh, come on!
I'm from London. Help me.
-No, no, no.
Look, here's the deal.
He's really cute.
-Oh, stop.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah, put both hands in.
[ Laughing ]
-Can someone give me a clue
before...do I...?
-That one's closer.
That one, the left.
That one's --
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh!
♪♪
Oh, my God. What is it?
Oh, my God. It's, like,
sticky and disgusting.
It's like -- bleh.
-Yeah, look at your thumb.
Don't touch it anymore.
Your finger's gonna
get all black.
-I have no --
-This is mascara. Sorry.
[ Buzzer ]
Sorry about that.
I apologize.
Oh, no! I should have
given you this one, sorry.
-Oh, it's okay.
-That one's got egg hair on it.
Oh, my God. Alright.
-Wow.
-Alright, here we go.
Now Victoria, this is time
for the final round.
-Okay.
-I just want to say
to the writers,
I hate you all and...
Alright, for this one, we both
get to get the same item.
The first person
to guess it wins.
[ Exhales deeply ]
I'll put my in through this way.
-Okay.
-You put yours in that way,
yeah.
[ Breathing heavily ]
[ Audience screams ]
-You go first.
-What do you mean? No!
We go in the same time, bud.
♪♪
-You got this, Jimmy!
-Ahh! It's warm! It's warm!
It's warm! It's warm!
It's warm!
It's warm! I felt it!
I kind of thought
it's warm in there.
It's warm in there!
Ugh! Oh!
Ohh!
Ahh!
You're in?
-Come on!
[ Applause ]
-She's saying "don't do it."
-It's like, hair...
Ahh!
Something is...
Ow! Oh, my God!
-Oh, my God! Is it a real thing?
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-You're an idiot!
This is wrong, people.
-Oh, my God.
-So sorry. I'm sorry that
that happened to you.
My thanks to Victoria Beckham.